it looks like the Democrats have an
Israel problem the squad are blaming
Israel for hamas's brutal and murderous
terrorist attack and calling for an end
to USA to the Jewish state
representative Rashida Talib and Corey
Bush both slamming Israel as an aparti
State now guys I'm just going to go
around the table I'm not going to ask
you a question hit it Greg all right
happy Columbus Day oh yes we forgot that
it's Columbus Day I say that knowing
that to some that's hate speech but I
think today is the IAL end of all hate
speech when you have people on the
streets laughing and cheering for the
death and rape of Americans and people
around the world I don't want to hear
any more about hate speech from anyone
about misgendering a woman with a penis
that's gone the ship has sailed because
you're the same people that are
defending this how quickly will the
scope of Israel's response be used
against Israel how dare you hurt
innocent civilians say the people
cheering the murder of innocent
civilians Dana well unfortunately ideas
become trendy on the left the way that
fashion does sort of around the world
and for a while the hatred against
Israel was really confined sort of to
Academia but it's it's spread and I
think that is very scary and you when I
listened to some of the um chanting
yesterday at the rally here in New York
City it was extremely chilling the last
thing I would say is uh Gretchen Whitmer
governor of Michigan she's being floated
as a possible presidential candidate for
the Democrats right I know a lot of
Democrats like her she could not even
bring herself to say she basically her
statement was like a thing happened
people are upset we acknowledge moving
on I to me I was like wow that does not
say show strength sounds like illan Omar
some people did something exactly yeah
no that was a remarkable statement I I
couldn't I couldn't the Saud were strong
you had you had to read it three times
uh no uh you know um obviously Joe Biden
kind of broke the sound barrier of
rhetoric when he started calling
everybody that doesn't vote for for
Nazis and semi fascists um and so it's
sort of not surprising but the bottom
line is when people tell you who they
are believe them Jessica I obviously
missed the part where Biden called
everyone who didn't vote for him a Nazi
or fascist um but the left has had an
Israel problem for a long time here Alan
Omar Rashida Talib Cory bush is newer uh
to Congress what they're what they' have
said is abhor um there is a way to
acknowledge um the humanity and the
Innocence uh what's gone on here and
acknowledge you know Gaza half of Gaza
are children um will some of them grow
up to be Hamas Fighters I'm sure all of
them absolutely not um I hate this it's
Bleak uh the best of us are Congressman
Richie Torres for instance uh Corey
Booker I should add and Daniel Goldman
who's my local Congressman were in
Israel over the weekend um when this
happened uh the Democratic party is
stronger when it supports Israel and we
that the fact the fact that local
congressmen were there kind of shows you
how our intelligence is so bad hi
everyone I'm Brian kilme I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming you way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now